police in Northern Virginia are
investigating after a 12 year old
african-american girl said three white
classmates pinned her down and cut her
dreadlocks the sixth grade girl says the
boys held her down on the playground of
the private Christian school in
Springfield during recess this week she
says they called her dreadlocks nappy
and like big chunks of my hair just cut
I the girl says she's been bullied by
the same boys before her family pays
$12,000 a year for her to attend this
school the school issued a statement
saying we take seriously the emotional
and physical well-being of all of our
students and have a zero-tolerance
policy for any kind of bullying or abuse
it's very disturbing about these boys
because it's heartbreaking and
traumatizing to that little girl
what's going to happen to them it
doesn't make sense to me that they would
get to stay in that's what they say
zero-tolerance we'll see what that means
that may be putting aside even putting
aside the significance of dreadlocks
Harry's part of the body that is an
assault on someone finally sad is that
she didn't tell her family for a couple
of days she didn't she didn't they just
noticed that her hair was shorter yeah
when they asked her about it and she
broke down it was totally understand
that it's not clear why there weren't
any teachers nearby when this happened
police are investigating